chat you constantly Google why do people
have to [ __ ] and regularly end
astonishing text conversations with
complaints about having to [ __ ] well
you've sent dozens of pictures of your
own [ __ ] to friends and you constantly
coax them into conversations about how
much you love [ __ ] will in chat you
must now debate which is better [ __ ]
or not [ __ ] and remember will no
impersonations thank you okay this is
game slimers
why is it game slimers
oh my God all right well we've done game
Slammers once before and it was about
games yeah it was about uh Chris Pratt
doing Mario's voice which we could
figure out the game part of that because
it's Super Mario right but why slimers
dude I don't know how this has anything
to do with games or slimers but this is
a truth
I don't like [ __ ] and you do
and now we are supposed to debate what
is better [ __ ] or not [ __ ]
so I guess I'll launch the opening cell
though
but wait a minute wait this before you
do okay uh hold on just one second dude
um
now just well well
you can't well look I think the whole
point of why doozy didn't want you to do
impersonations is so we could actually
have conversations about this [ __ ] and
now you're just [ __ ] doing it without
the Hulk Hogan voice you didn't you
didn't let me finish you didn't let me
start I was gonna say well said dude
okay thank you so this is why [ __ ]
is bad and why I abhor it it is a waste
of time just just please just just let
me get this one thing out I don't I'm
sorry please I don't send I used to and
doozy has access to everything I don't
send dozens of pics to my friends of my
[ __ ] I have yeah you haven't in a while
but yeah I mean I've got an archive of
them I'm sure somewhere in my [ __ ]
camera well yeah or doozy has them it's
a lot of fun to do that I'm a 47 year
old man I don't do it as much anymore I
really enjoyed doing that more in my 20s
and 30s okay so [ __ ] to me is in the
same category as sleeping pissing eating
anything
that takes time away from doing fun [ __ ]
from doing interesting [ __ ] that you
have to do in service of keeping this
[ __ ] [ __ ] body walking around and
[ __ ] existing I absolutely hate
existing in a physical body all I want
to do is think and be pure [ __ ]
thought and [ __ ] specifically is
abhorrent to me because it's also dirty
it's [ __ ] unclean you have to then
bathe afterwards no I do enjoy bathing I
will say I take four to five baths a day
he takes baths yeah he doesn't take
showers but they're not all for
cleanliness summer for warmth
um
it's true though yeah you do like this
but I really hate [ __ ] [ __ ] to
me is like you know a lot of people talk
about intelligent design look how
complex the [ __ ] human body is
there's no way that this could exist
without intelligent designer let me tell
you how [ __ ] intelligent the design
is you have to [ __ ] pack dead [ __ ]
down your mouth whether it's a [ __ ] a
corpse of a [ __ ] dead animal or a
[ __ ] dead plant or whatever you're
eating death and then you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] out this brown [ __ ] muck
that smells worse than anything on the
planet and you're doing this constantly
all [ __ ] day long then you spend a
third of your [ __ ] life unconscious
and some people like it I love taking a
good nap I love sleeping that's the
trick of it you feel good afterwards but
you've wasted a third of your [ __ ]
life being asleep pissing don't even be
started on pissing
yeah or piss blaming which we can't say
in a fun way because dudes he's decided
I hate I can't do them first I just hate
[ __ ] I hate eating I hate anything
that has to do with the [ __ ] the the
physical mechanics of the human [ __ ]
body get rid of it well [ __ ] you like
[ __ ] off then just don't [ __ ] well
this is who we are what are you talking
about you don't deserve to [ __ ] dude
okay make it stop if you could tell me
how to make [ __ ] stop I'm all ears
yeah well you know you don't deserve you
don't like [ __ ] no then you don't
deserve to [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
have a choice
yeah but you don't deserve it I love
taking a [ __ ] shooting is way better
than not [ __ ] and I'll explain to
you exactly why
Chad whether you like it or not these
are our Earthly carriages that we have
uh been blessed with yeah I know and
um uh you know we've evolved for
hundreds of thousands of years to become
the human beings that we are and even
longer is just you know life forms and
eventually now we're mammals right
um when I take a when I take a big
steaming stinky brown
[ __ ] prickly nut studded [ __ ]
you know yes when I take like a big
[ __ ] corn Laden
triple coil and [ __ ] like a like a
sausage as lulio would would say you
know like like a way way bigger than my
hole just a just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
stretch and
[ __ ] log right I feel
renewed I know that my body is working
because I love to consume uh the Flesh
of dead animals the animal bodies right
when when sometimes when Chad comes over
and we like order something and we're
hanging out and our friends and stuff I
say he goes what are you eat and I say
I'm having a I'm having a dead animal's
body yeah he's like a [ __ ] corpse you
know this is also get back to the
intelligent design thing if there is an
intelligent designer believe what you
will but if there is you must believe
this that Designer
loves [ __ ] because there's a million
different kinds of it and people are
doing it all day [ __ ] long [ __ ]
is such like an intrinsic part of the
human experience that if there was an
intelligent designer who created
Humanity they must love [ __ ] I think
there's no way around this you know who
else loves to [ __ ] his dick little boy
little lulio who
um
I love him so much and I love his poo
sometimes I just to freak my wonderful
fiance Molly out I'll literally take his
I'll go into the backyard and I'll just
pick his [ __ ] up with my bare hands if
she's around god well they're dry and
they're just fine and and she'll go what
are you what are you doing back there
and I'm like oh just cleaning up this
this poo and her reaction is
much uh more uh intense than yours is
and still I've never uh knowingly or
willingly farted in front of my Molly I
won't do that when you wash your hands
I've never washed her [ __ ] what's that
do you wash your hands after you touch
dogs of course I wash my hands what kind
of a disgusting scumbag Mongrel do you
think that I am Chad well let me ask you
this if you could press a button and not
ever have to [ __ ] again and always feel
as you said renewed after you [ __ ] you
always have the feeling of renewal but
you never have to [ __ ] would you do it
that's a really good
um yeah if there was another system if
there was another system to to digest
and I think that yeah that's a really
good point because I think that the
satisfaction I get is knowing that look
I eat a lot of vegetables lulio gives
you some good recipes one thing I like
to do is I just make a [ __ ] ton of green
vegetables and I've been grueling it up
Chad that's great yeah I I do a lot of
Veggie gruels same Molly loves my gruels
I'll do like you know a bunch of
different veggies yeah I've had some ear
grills they're very good cheers
um and uh I do the you're right if there
is however you um whatever you subscribe
to with regard to why we have these
bodies we have them and to me it's about
getting a bunch of you know sometimes
it's just about you know getting a bunch
of Swiss chard or collard greens or kale
right or even moving through the tubes
moving through the tubes what if we
didn't have the tubes that's where I'm
getting at the design of this
uh to me is terrible why do we have the
tubes at all why do I have to eat why do
I have to [ __ ] why do I have to piss why
do I have to sleep yeah just because of
evolution and where we are this [ __ ]
thing that we're all trapped in is
basically a long-term collection of
smaller pains that become bigger pains
that eventually end your life in an
arbitrary death I would like to do away
with all of it and for me [ __ ] is
kind of the Cornerstone of that entire
problem
[ __ ] what I don't know it's like
you're a you're a red-blooded [ __ ]
dude like me and you don't like to just
drop a [ __ ] huge dump no I am like
clockwork though I will say I wake up
within 10 to 15 minutes every morning
full expelling of uh all the rotten dead
plants that are in my body that's
digestion dude
thank you moving on please
[Music]